okay so we're going to play a quick
counting game uh the idea is you've got
to count from 1 to 100 everyone says
uh one number you cannot say a multiple
of seven or a number with a seven in it
so you go 1 2 3 4 5 6 8 9 10 11 12 13 15
16.
all right so what's happening
five six
eight nine 10 11 12 13
15 16
eighteen
twenty four twenty five
um as you can see you can play this game
up just from experience 27 28 is the
first one where they all stuff it up
because there's two in a row uh 42
people don't remember is a multiple of
seven um 56 57 is another double and so
you've got a few things that just
randomly create problems um i like to
play with your sevens and eights uh you
can do it as you can see with zero
equipment no
prep time at all uh you can do it
outside there's absolutely no reason why
you have to do it outside my kids like
that
in case you're wondering i do believe it
is actually a drinking game which i
visited
which i have rescued for education
and you can try different variables
you've got a really low e7 class do
fives
they can do fives if you've got uh a
good class you can try it in reverse so
every time you actually say all the
numbers but every time you hit a
multiple of seven you reverse so one two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen seventeen eighteen twenty three
so um so you can do that once you hit
seventy it gets really interesting you
had it did get to seventy and they got
so excited that someone said um eighty
four
so it um it works very easy to do only
takes a few minutes and as you can see
no prep time required that's my idea